[Musique]
françaises français
mes chers compatriotes d'hexagone
d'outre-mer et de l'étranger comme
depuis le début de la pandémie
je tiens à m'adresser directement à vous
après m'être beaucoup déplacé après
avoir été à votre rencontre partout en
france
après avoir longuement consulté où en
sommes nous de notre combat contre le
coc vide 19 grâce à l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos soignants grâce à
votre civisme à tous nous avons réussi à
maîtriser l'épidémie et à revivre à
nouveau nos effort proportionné la
réouverture progressive et réussi des
mois de mai juin et le déploiement d'un
plan de vaccination inédit nous ont
permis d'obtenir des résultats
incontestables
nous étions parvenus au cours de ces
dernières semaines à passer sous les
2000 contamination par jour contre plus
de 35000 au plus haut de la crise les
hospitalisations comme les décès sont au
plus bas depuis près d'un an en vous
disant tout cela je pense évidemment aux
victimes et à leurs proches
la vie malgré tout a pu continuer durant
ces mois difficiles parce que nous nous
sommes organisés collectivement si nous
avons demandé beaucoup aux enseignants
aux parents d'élèves qui ont dû
s'adapter dans l'urgence quand soudain
une classe fermée si nous avons demandé
beaucoup aussi à nos élèves et nos
étudiants
la france a largement préservés
l'instruction durant cette crise douze
semaines de fermeture pour nos écoles
depuis mars 2020 alors qu'aux états unis
les écoles ont fermé durant cinquante
six semaines ou en allemagne durant 34
semaines certains cours ont pu reprendre
physiquement à l'université ces derniers
mois nous pouvons être fiers de cela de
ce choix collectif de la nation d'avoir
fait le maximum pour l'avenir de nos
enfants et d'autre et de notre jeunesse
cet été comme à la rentrée nous
accentuerons encore nos efforts pour
apporter un soutien renforcé aux élèves
et aux étudiants qui rencontrent des
difficultés sur le plan économique le
quoi qu'il en coûte auquel je m'étais
engagé dès mars 2020 non seulement nous
a permis de protéger nos entreprises nos
emplois mais à préserver le pouvoir
d'achat de nombre de français et est à
l'origine d'un vigoureux rebond notre
croissance devrait s'établir à 6 % en
2021 en tête des grandes économies
européennes la france pour la deuxième
année consécutive a été désigné comme le
pays le plus attractif d'europe
contrairement aux prévisions l'emploi a
résisté et les acquis obtenus depuis
2010 est en termes de baisse dues somme
du chômage sont préservés en 2020 le coc
vide a détruit près de 300000 emplois
depuis le début de l'année nous avons
déjà re créé 187 milles emplois
ce seul mois de mai nous avons atteint
un nombre de contrats à durée
indéterminée créé inédit égalant notre
record de 2006 dans tous les secteurs
qui comme la culture l'hôtellerie la
restauration le sport le tourisme ont le
plus souffert
chacun reconnaît que les plans de
soutien spécifique que nous avons mises
en oeuvre ont permis d'empêcher les
drames humains les faillites et
d'envisager une reprise sereine
nous restons pleinement mobilisés pour
aider ceux qui ont subi la crise plus
fortement que d'autres
les salariés travaillant dans les
entreprises qui n'ont pas résisté
où les jeunes comme les indépendants qui
durant cette période sont
malheureusement tombés dans la pauvreté
je veux vous dire ce soir que nous avons
eu raison collectivement de rechercher
sans cesse l' équilibre entre la
protection et la liberté raison au début
de cette année de protéger la vie sans
pour autant refermer le pays
cette situation maîtrisée c'est le fruit
de nos choix de nos efforts
ces choix et nos résultats nous
permettent d'aborder les difficultés qui
sont encore devant nous avec
détermination
car oui
à l'heure où je vous parle notre pays
est confronté à une reprise forte de
l'épidémie qui touche tous les
territoires métropole comme outre-mer
aussi longtemps que le virus circulera
nous serons confrontés à ce type de
situation l'apparition du variant dit
delta se traduit en effet par une
augmentation des contaminations partout
dans le monde parce que ce variant est
trois fois plus contagieux que la
première souche il s'engouffre dans tous
les espaces non couverts par la
vaccination
pour y faire face de nouvelles mesures
de restriction ont été décidées aux pays
bas au portugal ou en espagne en asie et
dans le pacifique certains pays ont dû
se résoudre à un recond finement et le
japon imaginez qu'ils s'apprêtent à
organiser les jeux olympiques le fera
sans aucun spectateur
et si chez nous en france la situation
est pour le moment maîtrisé
si nous n'agissons pas dès aujourd'hui
le nombre de cas va continuer de monter
fortement et entraînera inévitablement
des hospitalisations en hausse dès le
mois d'août nous avons pour faire face à
cette nouvelle donne un atout maître qui
change tout par rapport aux vagues
précédentes le vaccin tous les vaccins
disponibles en france nous protège
solidement contre ce variant delta il
divise par 12 son pouvoir de
contamination est vite 95% des formes
graves
l'équation est simple plus nous
vaccinerons - nous le serons des espaces
au virus pour se diffuser plus nous
éviterons les hospitalisations et plus
nous éviterons d'autres mutations du
virus peut être plus dangereux encore
c'est donc une nouvelle course de
vitesse qui est engagée un été de
mobilisation pour la vaccination
voilà ce que nous devons viser vacciner
un maximum de personnes partout à tout
moment
nous sommes une grande nation une nation
de science celle des lumières de louis
pasteur
alors quand la science nous offre les
moyens de nous protéger nous devons les
utiliser avec confiance dans la raison
et dans le progrès pour nous protéger et
pour notre unité
nous devons aller vers la vaccination de
tous les français
car c'est le seul chemin vers le retour
à la vie normale dans un premier temps
pour les personnels soignants et non
soignants des hôpitaux des cliniques des
maisons de retraite des établissements
pour personnes en situation de handicap
pour tous les professionnels ou
bénévoles qui travaillent au contact des
personnes âgées ou fragiles y compris à
domicile
la vaccination sera rendue obligatoire
sans attendre j'ai conscience de ce que
je vous demande
je sais que vous êtes prêts à cet
engagement cela participe aux quelque
sorte de votre sens du devoir pour tous
nos compatriotes concernés ils auront
jusqu'au 15 septembre pour se faire
vacciner
il faut commencer dès maintenant à
partir du 15 septembre des contrôles
seront opérés et des sanctions seront
prises il ya ensuite tous les autres
françaises et français les millions
d'entre vous qui n'ont pour le moment
reçu aucune injection en fonction de
l'évolution de la situation nous devrons
sans doute nous poser la question de la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
français mais je fais le choix de la
confiance et j'appelle solennellement
tous nos concitoyens non vaccinés à
aller se faire vacciner dès aujourd'hui
au plus vite
9 millions de doses vous attendent dès
aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas encore été
injectés et nos commandes continuent
d'arriver
que ce soit donc près de chez vous sur
votre lieu de vacances avec ou sans
rendez vous faites vous vacciner
c'est la seule façon de vous protéger et
de protéger les autres
c'est une question de responsabilité
individuelle de sens de l'esprit
collectif
c'est aussi ce dont dépend notre liberté
à toutes et tous
je pense en particulier à tous nos
concitoyens de plus de 60 ans et aux
personnes vulnérables dont celles qui
sont en surpoids graves qu'ils sont pas
encore vaccinés aujourd'hui vous êtes
celles et ceux qui courent est
aujourd'hui le plus grand danger
j'en appelle donc à votre mobilisation
nous déploierons durant tout l'été la
vaccination au plus près du terrain
en travaillant étroitement avec nos
médecins nos pharmaciens mais aussi nos
associations dont je veux saluer
l'engagement et nous irons vacciner
celles et ceux qui sont aussi le plus
loin des soins pour les collégiens les
lycéens les étudiants des campagnes de
vaccination spécifique seront déployés
dans les établissements scolaires dès la
rentrée
je veux m'adresser enfin à ceux qui
vacciner les premiers c'est à dire en
janvier et février verront prochainement
leur taux d'anticorps baissé et leur
immunité diminué je veux ici les
rassurer dès la rentrée une campagne de
rappel sera mise en place pour vous
permettre de bénéficier d'une nouvelle
injection selon le même système et dans
les mêmes conditions que la ou les
premières les rendez vous pourront être
pris dès les premiers jours du mois de
septembre
il n'est donc pas d'inquiétude à avoir
mais malgré le vaccin je vous demande à
toutes et tous de continuer à être
prudents et de continuer à respecter ces
gestes barrière contre le virus que vous
connaissez bien désormais en complément
de la vaccination nous allons devoir
mettre en place de nouvelles mesures
pour freiner le virus parce que le
niveau de vaccination y est encore très
insuffisant et que les hôpitaux sont
déjà sous forte pression forte pression
l'état d'urgence sanitaire sera déclaré
dès demain en conseil des ministres pour
la martinique et la réunion et un
couvre-feu sera instauré pour autant
dans l'hexagone sauf dans les
départements qui dépasserait un taux
d'incidence de 200 et verraient leur
hospitalisation augmenter ou des mesures
de freinage pourront être prises par nos
préfets notre approche sera plus simple
partout nous aurons la même démarche
reconnaître le civisme et faire porter
les restrictions sur les noms
ciné plutôt que sur tous dès cette
semaine les contrôles aux frontières
seront encore renforcées pour les
ressortissants en provenance des pays à
risque avec un isolement contre un pour
les voyageurs non vaccinés dès le 21
juillet le pass sanitaire sera étendue
aux lieux de loisirs et de culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
récents ce pass est disponible sur
l'application tout senti qu vide mais
chacun peut utiliser la version papier
remise au moment de la vaccination à
partir du début du mois d'août
et cela parce qu'il nous faut faire
d'abord voté un texte de loi et le
promulguer à partir du début du mois
d'août donc le pass sanitaire
s'appliquera dans les cafés les
restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux mais aussi dans les avions
trains et cars pour les longs trajets là
encore seuls les vaccinés et les
personnes testées négatives pourront
accéder à ces lieux qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs clients usagers ou salariés
en fonction de l'évaluation de la
situation nous nous poserons la question
de l'extension du pass sanitaires à
d'autres activités encore cet automne
les fameux tests pcr seront rendus
payants
sauf prescription médicale et ceci afin
d'encourager la vaccination plutôt que
la multiplication des tests pour pouvoir
faire tout cela je convoquerai le
parlement en session extraordinaire à
partir du 21 juillet pour l'examen d'un
projet de loi qui déclinera ses
décisions vous l'avez compris la
vaccination n'est pas tout de suite
obligatoire pour tout le monde mais nous
allons étendre au maximum le pass
sanitaires pour pousser le maximum
d'entre vous à aller vous faire vacciner
enfin nous continuerons d'agir pour
éviter l'apparition de variants qui
pourrait être plus dangereux encore que
le variant delta
cela passe par un projet immense mais
indispensable est désormais à notre
portée vacciner le monde
la france depuis mars 2020 et à
l'initiative avec le programme act as
qui vise à la fois produire davantage de
vaccins et à donner aux pays les plus
pauvres
davantage de vaccins nous avons déjà
donné plus de deux millions et demi de
doses et d'ici la fin de l'année donnant
plusieurs dizaines de millions de doses
de vaccins
nous contribuerons à nous mobiliser
justement et à mobiliser tous nos
partenaires pour produire plus et donner
encore davantage aux pays les plus
pauvres en particulier dans les balkans
en afrique au proche et au moyen-orient
plusieurs pays sont aujourd'hui
fortement touchés et nous allons
accroître encore notre aide et je pense
particulièrement à la tunisie pour en
finir durablement avec la pandémie
nous devons vacciner partout je vous
l'avais dit l'année dernière nous
allions devoir vivre avec le virus
ce sera le cas tout au long de cette
année 2021 et sans doute pour plusieurs
mois encore de l'année 2022
même si le vaccin change beaucoup de
choses les semaines à venir seront donc
celle de la mobilisation pour bloquer le
virus et pour continuer de relancer
notre économie
l'été de mobilisation pour la
vaccination sera aussi un été de relance
gelé constaté au cours de mes récents
échanges avec vous partout en france
notre plan de relance se déploie un
rythme soutenu sur les 100 milliards
d'euros votés à l'automne dernier et
permet grâce à l'accord européen
historique d'il ya un an 40 milliards
ont ainsi été mobilisés sur le terrain
nous devons faire plus encore car plus
vite nous concrétiserons le plan de
relance plus fort sera notre rebond plus
relance plus efficace sera notre lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique
un tiers des crédits sont en effet ciblé
sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments sur les énergies décarbonées
sur l'automobile zéro émission tous les
secteurs qui concilie écologie et
économie écologie et progrès le
gouvernement et les préfets s'assureront
durant l'été de la bonne mise en oeuvre
des investissements sur le terrain nous
allons aussi faire le maximum pour lever
les contraintes
qui pèsent sur les secteurs justement
qui sont les plus en tension et sur vous
tous d'abord le manque de matières
premières qu'il s'agisse de bois d'acier
de fer ou du semi-conducteur ce qui a
retardé de nombreux chantiers et fait
monter les coûts ensuite les pénuries de
main d'oeuvre
selon la banque de france près d'une
entreprise sur deux ne trouvent pas de
réponses à ces offres d'emploi il faut
ainsi tout faire ensemble sur le terrain
pour y répondre et responsabiliser
chacun notre priorité de l'été et de
l'automne est bien de retrouver non
seulement le niveau d'emploi d'avant
l'épidémie b ne doute de nous réinscrire
dans une trajectoire de plein emploi
si nous nous mobilisons pour nous
vacciner pour relancer l'économie alors
nous serons en mesure en septembre de
préparer collectivement notre avenir
il nous faudra en débattre de manière
apaisée démocratique
il nous faudra aussi prendre des
décisions mais je veux d'ores et déjà
partager avec vous quelques convictions
fortes
la première c'est la nécessité de moins
dépendre de l'étranger pour certains
produits essentiels certains services
certaines technologies
c'est la nécessité de retrouver le
chemin d'une indépendance française et
européenne parce que nous avons vécu
durant cette crise
les conséquences de la dépendance grâce
à l'action menée depuis 2010 est nous
sommes en train de réussir de nous
améliorer les productions majeures pour
la vie du pays comme celles de
paracétamol par exemple ont été
relocalisés en france une usine géante
de batteries pour nos véhicules
électriques va prochainement ouvrir sur
nos terres industrielles du nord et
préfigurer des investissements massifs
dans la transformation de l'industrie
automobile j'ai lancé le mois dernier un
plan d'investissement de 7 milliards
d'euros pour l'innovation en matière de
santé d usine de la recherche chez nous
en france
nous sommes depuis deux ans la première
nation européenne du numérique et de la
technologie
nous devons donc continuer d'investir et
encourager ces initiatives qui ont créé
plus de 160 mille emplois ce défi
désormais qui est le nôtre et de changer
d'échelle de généraliser partout cette
dynamique de re devenir une grande
nation de recherche d'innovation
d'agriculture et d'industrie
réindustrialiser réconcilier la
croissance et l'écologie de production
au niveau national la baisse des impôts
de production ainsi que celle de l'impôt
sur les sociétés que nous avons décidé
vont permettre d'accélérer ce mouvement
au niveau européen la présidence
française de l'union européenne qui
commencera le 1er janvier 2022 nous
permettra de bâtir un agenda commun
d'indépendance industriel et
technologique à la rentrée après le
travail et les consultations en cours
nous déciderons d'un plan
d'investissement qui visera un objectif
bâtir la france de 2030 et faire émerger
dans notre pays né en europe
les champions de demain qui dans les
domaines du numérique de l'industrie
verte des biotechnologies ou encore de
l'agriculture
d sinon notre avenir la deuxième
conviction c'est que nous avons vu la
force durant cette crise de notre modèle
social
ils à protéger nos entreprises nos
emplois notre culture de nombreux
secteurs exposés et la protéger notre
pouvoir d'achat durant la crise c'est un
joyau qu'il nous faut préserver ce
modèle social français repose sur un
fondement le travail sans travail pas de
production sans travail et sans
production pas de financement de notre
santé pas de financement du chômage
partiel pas de financement de nos
retraites
la priorité de la sortie de crise sera
donc la même que depuis le début du
quinquennat le travail et le mérite
c'est pour cela que nous allons
continuer d'investir dans la formation
tout haut
de l'avis dès cette rentrée nous formons
durablement plus de demandeurs d'emploi
qu'il ya quatre ans mais ce n'est pas
encore assez
j'ai demandé au gouvernement dès cette
rentrée de lancer un plan massif de
formation et de requalification des
chômeurs de longue durée
c'est pour cela que la réforme de
l'assurance chômage sera pleinement
mises en oeuvre dès le 1er octobre
autour d'une volonté simple en france on
doit toujours bien mieux gagner sa vie
en travaillant en restant chez soi ce
qui n'est actuellement pas toujours le
cas
c'est pour cela aussi que nous devrons
engager dès que les conditions
sanitaires seront réunies la réforme des
retraites
j'ai toujours tenu un langage de vérité
oui notre système est injuste
avec quarante deux régimes différents il
entretient des inégalités majeur il
faudra aller vers plus de simplicité
pour plus de justice et donc les régimes
spéciaux devront être supprimés pour les
nouveaux employés dans ces secteurs
oui parce que nous vivons plus longtemps
il nous faudra travailler plus longtemps
et partir à la retraite plus tard à
demain pas brutalement pas de manière
uniforme car il faut prendre en compte
la difficulté des métiers mais
progressivement sur plusieurs années et
par un système qui fait la différence
selon le travail réellement exercées et
donc l'âge de départ doit être plus
tardif oui une vie de travail doit
offrir une pension digne et donc toute
retraite pour une carrière complète
devra être supérieure à 1000 euros par
mois voilà ce que je veux
en des termes clairs et simples pour
protéger les retraites actuelles et
celles de nos enfants sans augmenter les
impôts
il est juste et efficace de changer
notre système de retraite
j'ai entendu les débats sur le moment
faut-il faire cette réforme dès ce mois
de juillet à la rentrée ou bien plus
tard alors si je demande aux
gouvernements de jean castex de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
sur ce sujet dès la rentrée je ne
lancerai pas cette réforme tant que
l'épidémie ne sera pas sous contrôle et
la reprise bien assurer ma troisième
conviction enfin c'est que la nation
doit tout une réponse à ceux qui ont été
le plus touchés par la crise à notre
jeunesse qui a tant sacrifié alors
qu'elles risquaient peu pour elle même à
nos aînés qui plus que les autres on
craint pour leur vie pour notre jeunesse
nous devons continuer d'investir
investir dans la petite enfance dans
l'éducation
cela demeure plus que jamais notre
priorité en sortie de crise pour nos
jeunes adultes
nos étudiants comme nos jeunes actifs ou
de jeunes qui sont peu formés
nous avons créé la plateforme un gène
une solution nous poursuivrons ce
programme qui a permis à deux millions
de jeunes de trouver une formation de
décrocher parfois un emploi de signer
souvent un contrat d'apprentissage
imaginez 526 mille contrats
d'apprentissage en 2020 ce qui est un
record pour amplifier cette dynamique je
présenterai à la rentrée le revenu
d'engagement pour les jeunes qui
concernera les jeunes sans emploi ou
formation et sera fondé sur une logique
de devoir est de droit
quant à nos aînés et nos concitoyens en
situation de handicap trop souvent
confrontés à une solitude sans solution
nous leur devons une grande ambition
humaniste pour l'autonomie un
accompagnement renforcé pour le maintien
à domicile des maisons de retraite
moderniser accompagnement de notre
jeunesse meilleure prise en charge des
aînés c'est un nouveau pacte français
entre les générations qu'il nous faut
bâtir pour notre nation
cette ambition devra être financé et ce
ne sera pas par une hausse d'impôts
là aussi je demeure constant avec la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation la
baisse des cotisations sociales
la diminution de l'impôt sur le revenu
ce qui représente 170 euros en plus par
mois pour un salarié au smic
nous avons assumé d'améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat est de baisser les impôts
une priorité pour les classes moyennes
et nous ne reviendrons pas en arrière
nos réformes ne seront pas davantage
financer
en laissant filer la dette la nouvelle
génération doit déjà assumer la dette
écologique je n'ajouterai pas ce fardeau
la dette financière la seule solution le
seul moyen d'assurer ce nouveau pacte
est de travailler davantage d'investir
d'innover d'inventer d'améliorer notre
croissance est de continuer à réformer
réformer l'état comme nous avons
commencé à le faire avec la réforme de
la haute fonction publique et la
suppression de l'ena de simplifier le
mille-feuille territorial de simplifier
partout où c'est possible
l'action publique la seule solution est
de continuer à bousculer le système et
des positions établies les rentes les
statuts c'est ainsi que nous reprendrons
le contrôle de notre destin comme nation
c'est ainsi que nous reprendrons chacun
le contrôle de nos vies comme citoyen la
volonté que la france doit porter est
bien celle-là reprendre le contrôle de
notre destin garantir à chacune et
chacun des nôtres qu'il pourra retrouver
de son destin personnel professionnel
familial et civiques
bien des questions devront trouver les
réponses dans les mois qui viennent que
je n'ai pas ici abordée dans le cadre de
ce message ce soir j'ai bien entendu
[Musique]
entendu l'inquiétude que fait naître la
montée d'une violence endémique dont
sont victimes les plus fragiles les
femmes souvent y compris dans le couple
de jeunes adolescents dans la rue et le
manque de respect à l'égard des forces
de l'ordre de sécurité j'ai entendu le
message porté à l'endroit de nos
institutions par l'abstention
impressionnante aux élections régionales
et départementales
mais j'ai en tête les questions qui
portent sur les équilibres de notre
démocratie
devant toutes ces questions j'ai une
certitude nous devons non seulement
prolonger notre effort mais le
renouveler en inventant chaque jour le
nouveau modèle que notre pays et le
monde attendent mais des choses dans le
monde sont en train de bouger aussi
grâce à des initiatives que proposait
soutient la france il faudra se souvenir
que c'est en ces premiers
jour de l'été 2021 que la communauté
internationale dans un effort sans
précédent a décidé d'une imposition
mondial des multinationales à 15 %
minimum mettant ainsi fin aux évasions
fiscales et aux paradis fiscaux
la france a été en première ligne et à
contribuer à faire bouger l'europe et le
monde
mes chers compatriotes cet été de
retrouvailles et de retour aux sources
cet été qui sera fait de moments amicaux
et familiaux devra donc être néanmoins
été de vigilance de lutte contre le
virus de vaccination j'ai confiance en
vous confiance en nous pour rester unis
serein et déterminé alors à la rentrée
nous auront rendez vous avec notre
avenir pour bâtir une france
indépendante qui ne vit pas dans la
nostalgie mais c'est prendre les
décisions nécessaires à sa destinée une
france conquérante qui a foi en la force
de sa jeunesse et n'a pas peur du futur
mais l'un vante une france unie qui sait
être solidaire civique responsable dans
l'épreuve comme dans la conquête
vive la république et vive la france
[Musique]